Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David P.
Here is a voicemail that is going to upset people
in my audience because it is someone saying,
Hey David, as progressives, maybe we shouldn't
be so anti cryptocurrency. Oh, this will.
This will upset some people. Take a listen.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, this is moving on from
Minneapolis. I wanted to call and commend
you on your stance on crypto and NFT.
I'm a progressive and also a crypto
investor, and I'm just saddened because I see
so many progressive thought leaders demonizing
the entirety of crypto. Well, entertaining, like
reasonable discourse on how to properly regulate
it. I mean, it's almost it seems like they're like
Trump, like with their rhetoric. Sometimes to me,
the problem is like, crypto is such a big idea.
It's like the internet so like to paint the entire
sector as a Ponzi or scam rises to almost Trumpian
levels of immaturity. It's not perfect, and it
needs regulation, but there's a reason this thing
continues to grow. And I think there's like, I
think it's here to stay and I fail to see how
progressives win by demonizing it. I mean, they
might even win like some votes by helping lead
the discussion on reasonable regulatory policy.
Speaker 1: Yeah, listen, this is this is really
painful to me that there is such a lack
of balance from many of my friends on the
left on this issue of cryptocurrency. It's
almost like it's a trigger word. You hear
cryptocurrency or you hear the word bitcoin, and
it's immediately like no bad scam, illegal crime
right away. And there's also kind of like a
naivete or maybe an arrogance to think that,
you know, the future of this entire space that you
know, whether this is something that's going to be
viable or not. I think some humility should tell
us, we don't know, and that's kind of the whole
point. Cryptocurrency is clearly here to stay. To
some degree, been around more than a decade. Major
Wall Street financial advisers now say to most
people, it's not unreasonable to have, you know,
one to three two to four percent of assets in
cryptocurrency for diversification. It's volatile,
but it's been around a long time. There are
cryptocurrency ETFs moving in the direction
of mutual funds. We don't have to like it, but
the idea that any second is going to evaporate
seems increasingly unlikely. Now, I think the
other thing that's important is a lot of the
bullet points. And again, just as a reminder, I
don't care about cryptocurrency any more than I
care about mutual funds or stocks like I
want to just have a properly diversified
asset allocation for my risk tolerance with my
money. That's all I care about. Sometimes you'll
hear what crypto is mostly being held by wealthy
people, right? Just like the U.S. dollar. I mean,
you know, this is a systemic problem. Money is
mostly in the hands of the wealthy that's not
unique to cryptocurrency. So that is that really
the issue? Not to me is crypto used to complete
criminal transactions? Yeah, some. I mean,
apparently not that much. One interesting
thing was when the Silk Road got shut down, it
was believed that the Silk Road was basically
the vast majority of bitcoin transactions.
And with with the Silk Road shut down,
bitcoin transactions would fall to almost zero. It
didn't happen. Crypto transactions barely declined
when the Silk Road was shut down. The dollar
has been used for way more crimes than bitcoin
has. It's just a reality. It doesn't tell us one
thing or the other. I'm not defending anything.
Does bitcoin mining not all crypto, but
does bitcoin mining have a carbon footprint?
Absolutely. Absolutely. And its impact, I mean,
it's not going to be sustainable unless that's
dealt with either through alternative energy.
Like that's that's a problem that's got to
be dealt with. And also. The legacy dollar and
banking industry has an insane carbon footprint.
All the dollars that are brought by tourists
to Europe are then flown back to the US. Do you
understand the carbon footprint of that armored
cars everywhere? Insane infrastructure of banks.
The overhead, they have private jets. I mean, it's
if you want to talk about that, let's talk about
it. But let's also consider other banking and
monetary instruments in the carbon footprint.
People hear this and they go, but it's not
the same. We'll just compare one by one,
and my view on crypto is nothing is only good.
The internet oh my god, child porn scams.
Right. But the internet exists and it's going
to exist. So we've got to control the child porn
in the scams, the stock market. It's rife with
scammers, fake financial advisors, Ponzi schemes.
Yes, we have to deal with that. But investors
investing in the stock market is not going to end,
you know, cars. I mean, they they put out
emissions and people die in car accidents. Yeah,
but less cars are going to exist, is it? We're not
at this point where I'm getting rid of cars, so
let's make them green. Let's switch to electric.
Let's make them safer. Let's redesign our roads.
I'm not even an evangelist that crypto exists. It
doesn't seem to be going anywhere. I put a small
portion of my assets in monthly dating back
to 2015, and that's it. I don't have all my
eggs in there. If crypto ends and goes to zero,
I lose what is now three to five percent. If it
does well, then I do it. It's not something
in and of itself that we should have this.
Reflexive reaction to. And the problem
is that when the left takes that view,
they just miss out on participating in how to
properly regulate crypto and they leave it to,
I don't know, the libertarians or whoever.
Let's take a more balanced view, please.
We've got a great bonus show for you today. Sign
up at Join Hoffman dot com. I will see you that.